I mentioned soup in terms of progress
there's been a little bit of tension a
little bit of love online in terms of
deep learning so I just wanted to say
that the kind of criticism and
skepticism about the limitations of deep
learning are really healthy in
moderation
Jeff hidden one of the three people to
receive the Turing award as as many
people know has said that the future
depends on some graduate student who is
deeply suspicious of everything I have
said so that suspicion skepticism is
essential but in moderation just a
little bit the more important thing is
perseverance which is what Geoffrey
Hinton and the others have had through
the winters of believing in your own
nets and an open - for returning to the
world of symbolic AI of expert systems
of complexity and cellular automata of
old ideas in AI and bringing them back
and see if there's ideas there and of
course you have to have a little bit of
crazy
nobody ever achieved something brilliant
without being a little bit of crazy and
the most important thing is a lot of
hard work
it's not the cool thing these days but
hard work is everything I like what JFK
said
bought us going to the moon us I was
born in the Soviet Union
see how I conveniently just said us
going to the moon is we do these things
not because they are easy but because
they're hard and I think that artificial
intelligence is one of the hardest and
most exciting problems there before us
so with that like to thank you and see
if there's any questions
[Applause]
you